[Music]
good morning John it's Monday October
15th John last Friday in order to
calculate the carbon flip on her brother
Hadoop I know you put a number on
something that I've been thinking about
for a while that thing that I've been
thinking about is the amount of time
that people spend watching but I have to
point out it's kind of hard for me to
come to terms with people have spent
over 16 years watching Brotherhood 2.0
16 years do you know what a person can
do in 16 years a person is the sum of a
person's actions and so our video box
the same way like Brotherhood 2.0 is as
Brotherhood 2.0 does does that mean that
because people have put 16 years of time
into the Brotherhood 2.0 project into
watching and creating and participating
in the Brotherhood 2.0 project that
Brotherhood 2.0 is now 16 years old and
if it is 16 years old then is this
successful 16 year old I mean I know
that it's not gonna get a car and it's
not gonna be able to drive a car but
frankly I think that's a good thing
because cars are bad I think for 16 year
old Brotherhood 2.0 is doing pretty good
for itself
how many sixteen year olds have their
own foundation to decrease worldsuck how
many sixteen year olds have thousands of
runs and a trickling income stream from
google ads in terms of the income
streams of 16 year olds Brotherhood 2.0
is probably pretty high up on the list
with its $30 a month $30 a month is
pretty good for a 16 year old especially
a 16 year old who mostly just watches
videos on YouTube
so yes the 16 year old Brotherhood 2.0
adolescent does generally just watch
videos on YouTube and very occasionally
does other things but the other things
that it does are good things it never
sleeps and it makes tiny amounts of
money and decreases worldsuck one thing
that Brothers 2.0 doesn't do is read
books but I like to think that if
Brotherhood 2.0 was a real person if it
jumped out of the computer screen with
all its combined experiences of everyone
who's ever watched or participated
Brotherton to play know that Brotherhood
2.0 would read a lot I think that it
would read books and its 16 and reading
books and so it would probably celebrate
tene read week sorry that's a plug to
read week y'all saw the young adult
library services something that starts
with a new check Association is
celebrating T read week which promotes
reading among teens which is a good
thing to read week recently in a video I
talked about how video blogs could
actually be a more effective medium for
transmitting ideas than books can be
however that is not always the case for
example Harry Potter would be a horrible
video blog if you want to read with me
I'm currently reading the lathe of
heaven which is not a young adult book
but it is only a hundred and sixty pages
long so it's kind of short and I've
heard that you kids like short books I
like short books too
John I've just run out of hard drive
space so I'll see you tomorrow Jane read
week